usually a bulldozer just pushes dirt
this Komatsu dozer with a unique blade
design that tilts can also scoop up dirt
and almost float it over the ground and
the reason that's a good idea is you're
not now pushing against the ground and
you don't have a lot of resistance
you're not trying to roll the dirt it's
an incredibly efficient machine and it
does its job very well there are only 45
of these beasts operating in the world
they're normally found in the larger
mines of America Canada and Australia
where long straight pushes of a name of
the game it definitely improved the
production on our mind so you can do so
much more work with with basically one
Operator and that's what makes it
feasible to have the machine this
machine isn't just about productivity
it's also about comfort what we were
trying to do is keep the track on the
ground whatever the track is off the
ground and slams back into the ground
you get shot up to the operator the
undercarriage of the super dozer follows
the contour of the ground with
independent seesaw like movements and to
further decrease vibration rubber shock
absorbers were added giving this machine
the best traction of any dozer on the
market a smooth ride over rough terrain
may be guaranteed by komatsu but what
about big objects in its path the
greatest ever pitted the D 575 a three
against a pickup truck yeah I think
that's a pretty silly idea that would
definitely fall into the unapproved
application format of a D 575
bulldozers take advantage of their
weight when dozing as the heavier the
machine the more traction it has to push
heavy loads this super dozer weighs a
hundred and fifty thousand kilos and
although it exerts only 26 kilos of
ground pressure per square centimeter
its massive overall weight quickly and
effortlessly turns the truck into
roadkill
that's one way to measure the weight of
this machine